[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الاعزاء بالتزامن مع
زياره معلنه للرئيس المصري عبد الفتاح
السيسي الى المانيا قررت محكمه جنايات
القاهره تاجيل النطق بالحكم في قضيتي تهم
التخابر
واقتحام السجون المنسوبه لمرسي وقيادات
اخوانيه الى الس 16س عشر من يونيو الجاري
لاتمام المداوله نتوقف مع هذا الخبر
لنناقش في محورين ما الذي نقراه في
التزامن بين تاجيل الحكم في قضيه مرسي
وقيادات الاخوان وزياره السيسي الى
المانيا والى اين سيؤ ملف هذه القضيه في
ظل المؤشرات المحيطه به داخل مصر وخارجها
[موسيقى]
وسط توقعات متضاربه اعلنت محكمه جنايات
القاهره تاجيل النطق في قضيتي التخابر
واقتحام السجون الى الس 16س عشر من يونيو
الجاري لاتمام المداوله وقالت المحكمه
نفسها انها تسلمت راي مفتي البلاد في
القضيتين وهو الراي الذي سيحسم انزال حكم
الاعدام من عدمه باول رئيس منتخب عرفته
مصر بعد قيام ثوره ال5 من يناير
غموض قضائي يستمر بالتزامن مع زياره معلنه
لعبد الفتاح السيسي الى المانيا التي سبقه
اليها جدل الماني واسع حول السجل الحقوقي
لنظامه قرات
المحكمه مد اجل النطق الى اسبوعين اخرين
اجل النطق بالحكم على الرئيس المصري
المعزول محمد مرسي في قضيتي ما يعرف
بالتخابر واقتحام السجون بعد ان احيلت
اوراقه واخرين الى المفتي في ال 16 من
مايو ايار الماضي فهل جاء قرار التاجيل
لاعتبارات قضائيه كما قالت المحكمه من اجل
استكمال المداولات بعد وصول راي المفتي
صباح الاثنين ام ثمه ابعاد اخرى لهذا
التاجيل لا سما وان التلويح باعدام مرسي
قد قوبل بحمله تنديد عالميه وادانه واسعه
من منظمات حقوق الانسان لم تخفف من
مزعم النظام المري حول استقلال القضاء من
المعلوم ان الرئيس عبد الفتاح السيسي
يتوجه الى المانيا في زياره تخيم عليها
اوضاع حقوق الانسان المتدهوره في مصر اذ
ان احتجاجات كبار الساسه الالمان سبقت
وصوله الى برلين حزب الخضر راى في الزياره
اشاره خاطئ وان كان لابد منها فعلى
المستشاره انجيلا ميركل ان تبلغ سيسي بان
اي دعم الماني سيكون مشروطا باجراء
انتخابات حره ونزيهه وقضاء مستقل سبق ذلك
اعلان رئيس البرلمان الالماني وهو عضو في
حزب ميركل انه لا يريد مقابله السيسي بسبب
قمعه للمعارضه والعدد غير المعقول من
احكام الاعدام الصادره في مصر حسب قوله
فهل يرتدع النظام المصري بتلك الضغوط خاصه
وانه يعقب رهانات كبيره على زياره رئيسه
الى المانيا واذا صح ذلك فعلى الارجح ان
يكون تاجيل الحكم على مرسي املته تلك
الزياره وهذا فضلا عن انه يؤكد هيمنه
السياسي على مجال القضاء فانه يشير الى ما
هو اخطر بمعنى ان الحكم المقرر على مرسي
هو الاعدام خاصه اذا ما ربط بتلك المصادفه
الغريبه المتمثله اعلان الكشف عما قالت
الداخليه المصريه انها خلايا سريه تابعه
لجماعه الاخوان منذ عهد مرسي تجمع معلومات
عن اجهزه الدوله وترسلها الى جهات خارجيه
وذلك الاعلان اريد منه ربما اولا تبرير ما
قد يصدر من حكم على الرئيس المخلوع ورفاقه
ثم ثانيا محاوله اظهار النظام المصري في
صوره من يواجه الارهاب وانه في موقف
دفاعي موضوع حلقتنا نناقشه مع ضيوفنا من
اسطنبول حمزه زوبع القيادي في حزب الحريه
والعداله ومن فريبورغ في سويسرا حاتم عزام
النائب السابق في البرلمان المصري ونائب
رئيس حزب الوسط المصري ومن واشنطن نبيل
ميخائيل استاذ العلوم السياسيه في جامعه
جورج واشنطن وابدا مع حمزه زوبع من
اسطنبول سيد حمزه كيف تقراون تاجيل الحكم
بالتزامن مع الزياره المعلنه غدا للرئيس
السيسي الى الى
المانيا ا بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم نقراه
كما نقرا كل قرارات وتحركات قائد الانقلاب
انه يخشى الغرب ويخشى ميركل ويخشى الناس
في الخارج لكنه لا يحترم شعبه ولا
يحترم وطنه ولا يحترم اي شيء ليس عنده
قانون ليحترم ليس عنده دستور ليحترم
هذا الرجل يبحث عن شرعيه مفقوده ويعرف انه
بعد عامين وهو يزور المانيا اليوم لا يجد
له صديق ولا يجد له رفيق بل يجد معارضه
مستمره من الاحرار في مصر وخارج مصر يجد
مناوه
ويعني مواقف صعبه قالت وكاله الانباء
الالمانيه ان زياره
السيسي الى المانيا هي زياره الضيف الصعب
عاوز اقولها بالمصري الضيف الثقيل حين
يقول يقوم رئيس البرلمان ويصرح انه لن
يلتقي
بالسيسي لانه قاتل ولانه ولانه ويقوم حزب
الخضر ويفعل ذلك يكون الرد من السيسي انه
والله عندنا اكتشفنا جماعات معرفش ايه
وطلعوا بيان بالامس وبعدين اليوم يقوم
ياجل السؤال لماذا اجل الى يوم 16 طيب ما
كان عنده فرصه كويسه يقول للعالم ان انا
راجل كويس
ومحترم وما بقتل مثلا يطلعهم يلغي حكومه
عقوبه الاعدام او المفتي ويلغي اليوم 16
ليه ياجل اليوم 16 ليه لان يوم 15 يا
حضرات يوم 15 يونيو في قمه افريقيه فهو
هيطلع من ميركل بعد اسبوعين هيروح القمه
الافريقيه فمش عاوز يروح هناك وحكم
الاعدام متعلق في رقبته هو يخشى الناس
خشيه كبيره لكنه اينما يتوجه سيواجه بعقو
بعقبات وبصعوبه وبتحدي الثوره المصريه لم
تخمد نيرانها بعد سيد نبيل ميخيل مستمره
سيد نبيل
ميخائيل الرئيس السيسي يخشى الناس ويخشى
مواجهه الدول الاوروبيه والدول
الديمقراطيه
وبرقبتى مرتقب او احكام اعدام سبق وان نفذ
ما
رايك
ا هناك قضيتين في هذا الامر الموضوع الاول
هو لماذا تم تاجيل النطق بالحكم في قضيه
التخابر اللي بتشمل الدكتور محمد مرسي
وايضا يعني تعامل الرئيس السيسي مع قضايا
الاسلاميين انا بقول ان تاجيل الحكم سببه
تقارير امنيه قالت ان ممكن ان تكون هنا
هناك اضطرابات في عده مواقع في داخل القطر
المصري كرد فعل على احتمال النطق بالحكم
بالاعدام ضد الرئيس مرسي وعدد من
مساعديه لكن هذا الامر حصل اليوم عفوا سيد
نبيل حصل اليوم او حصل بعد 15 يوما بعد
الس 16س عشر من يونيو كما هو الموعد في اي
وقت يمكن ان يتم النطق بحكم الاعدام هناك
توقعات امنيه بان تكون هناك ردود افعال
فما الذي سيتغير بين اليوم وال 16س عش من
يونيو ان لم يكن الموضوع مرتبط بالزياره
حاجه الصوت انقطع انا ما قدرتش اكمل حديثي
امم في مشكله فنيه طيب ا ساعود اليك سيد
نبيل ميخائيل ريثما يتم حل المشكله
التقنيه بالصوت وانتقل الى السيد حاتم
عزام من فريبور في في سويسرا سيد
حاتم الى اي مدى تعتقد ان هناك ارتباط
وثيق فعلا بين الزياره والمواقف التي صدرت
عشيه الزياره من الاحزاب الالمانيه
الفاعله ورئيس البرلمان الالماني وبين
التاجيل تاجيل النطق
بالحكم تحياتي لحضرتك يا استاذ حسن
ولضيوفك الكرام وساده المشاهدين في كل
مكان بكل تاكيد ان انه كل ما يتم منذ
انقلاب الثالث من يوليو 2013 حتى الان في
الشان القضائي هو مسيز
بامتياز بدايه من التهمه الموجهه لرئيس
منتخب وهي تهمه التخابر
مع حركه المقاومه الفلسطينيه حماس الى
اقتحام السجون اللي كلنا عارفين كل من
شارك في ثوره 25 يناير يعلم ان هذه تهما
تهما يعني مضحكه
مبكيه الامر الاخر انه التسريبات التي
وثقت من جهات عديده مهنيه زي شركه جي بي
فرانش مورجان جي بي فرانش
اسوشيتس الخاصه بممدوح
شاهين المسؤول القانوني للمجلس العسكري
وعبد الفتاح السيسي ومدير مكتبه اللي هم
كيف اختطفوا الرئيس وحطوه في مكان احتجزوه
في مكان غير معروف وبالمخالفة
لو لو فرض انهم من حقهم يحكموه هذا غير
صحيح وبالتالي هناك العديد من المؤشرات
والممارسات التي تؤكد تسييس القضاء بل
تحويله الى اداه من ادوات الانقلاب
العسكري لابد ان نشير هنا الى تصريحات
رئيس البرلمان الالماني ورفضه لمقابله
السيسي ورئيس البرلمان هنا يعبر عن الشعب
الالماني فبرغم استقبال انجلا ميركل وهي
الرئيسه التنفيذيه رئيسه الوزراء
التنفيذيه الا انه رئيس البرلمان وهو من
يعبر عن الشعب يرفض هذا الاستقبال بسبب
هذه الاحكام الجائره
المسيسه السيسي هيكون في موقف هذه الصوره
التي رسمتها فقط باختصار هل تضعها كلها
وراء تاجيل النطق بالحكم حاليا الى مرحله
سياسيه قد يجدها السيسي اكثر مناسبه
بالنسبه للنطق
بالحكم نعم انا اعتقد انه عبد الفتاح
السيسي يفعل كل ما هو مجنون وكل ما
هو يعني يتسم بالجرائم ضد الانسانيه منذ
3/7 حتى الان سواء من قتل او اعتقال او
تعذيب حتى الموت زي ما شفنا في السجون
المصريه وبالتالي هو يؤرقه تماما وجود
رئيس منتخب له شرعيه وبالتالي هو ماضي في
من وجهه نظري في تنفيذ الحكم ولكن اجله
لانه سيسافر الى الغرب وهذا الغرب قد اعلن
تحفظه على هذه الاحكام
ثم هناك قمه افريقيه كما تفضل الدكتور
زوبع وهو يريد ان يعدي كل هذه او يمر من
كل هذه المطبات له حتى لا ادري كنت سي سيد
حاتم لا ادري ان كنت قد تبعت السيد نبيل
ميخائيل من واشنطن اريد ان اعود اليه سيد
نبيل قلت
بانه الارتباط له علاقه بتقارير امنيه
تقول بانه يمكن ان يكون هناك اضطرابات
امنيه لو جرى النطق بالحكم اليوم لكن
سالتك انه لو كان اليوم او غدا او حتى بعد
اسبوعين كما هو مقرر نفس هذه التقارير سوف
تقول انه ربما تكون هناك اضطرابات امنيه
فلماذا اليوم جرى تاجيل النطق
بالحكم اولا اسسف انقطع الخط لاني ما
قدرتش استكمل الحديث ممكن يكون هناك رد
فعل بعد اسبوعين ثلاثه لكن عامل التوقيت
عامل مهم جدا ربما تكون الحكومه المصريه
واجهزه الدوله في موقف يسمح لها بالتعامل
افضا مع اي مشكله امنيه ا انا في رايي ان
موضوع النطق باحكام ضد الرئيس مرسي وغيره
سيكون محل مناقشه ما بين المسؤولين
الالمانيين برئاسه المستشاره ميركل
والرئيس السيسي ومعاونين اوروبا هنصح مصر
بلا ينفذ
الحكم النطق به فربما تكون هناك تصريحات
من مسؤولين مصريين من دلوقتي لغايه معاد
نطق بالحكم سواء 16 يونيا او فيما بعد
اولا هو مش هيتزاع مع ذكرى الاطاحه بحكومه
الاخوان المسلمين لان 30 يوني هيبقى يعني
اك معاد لاكثر من مناسبه ام فهو هيكون في
اطار زمني ما بين منتصف يونيا لغايه اخر
الشهر ربما تصدر تصريحات من مسؤولين
مصريين بما فيها فضيله المفتي نفسه تحاول
يعني شرح ما هو معنى الحكم حتى لو صدر حكم
بالاعدام يمكن تخفيفه يمكن الاعفاء عنه
يمكن تحويله الى هيئه اخرى مثل رئاسه
الجمهوريه فاعتقد ان حيكون هناك صلاحيات
وممارسات كثيره تهيئ الشعب المصري لتقبل
النطق بالحكم على كل هذه النقطه هذه
النقطه بالتحديد سيد نبيل سنعود اليها حول
مالات ملف هذه القضيه في ظل المؤشرات
المحيطه ب بهذا الملف داخل مصر وخارجها
لكن بعد الفاصل مشاهدينا ابقوا
[موسيقى]
معنا اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد في هذه
الحلقه التي تناقش الخلفيات الحقيقيه
لتاجيل النطق في قضيه مرسي وقيادات
الاخوان تزامنا مع زياره السيسي الى
المانيا واعود الى حمزه زوبع القيادي في
حزب الحريه والعداله من اسطنبول سيد حمزه
في ضوء المواقف الدوليه الرافضه والمنتقد
لحكم الاعدام والنصائح الدوليه للسيسي
بعدم صدور الحكم او تنفيذ هكذا حكم الى
اين يمكن ان يقول هذا الملف
برايك طيب اولا قبل ما اجاوب على الحكايه
دي لازم اقول للاخ نبيل ان الحكومه التي
جاءت ليست حكومه الاخوان المسلمين التي
اطيح بها لقد تم الاطاحه بنظام رئاسي وببر
لمان جاء باراده الشعب ممثلا عن الشعب
وليس ممثلا عن الاخوان المسلمين فانا ار
به كاستاذ للعلوم السياسيه ان يزيف
التاريخ والحقيقه امام الراي العام في
الجزيره هذه واحده الثانيه انه السيسي
مراوغ يعني وهو جاء لمهمه واضحه مهمه
السيسي هي اما نحن واما هم سنقتل او
ينصاعوا ل هذا ما قاله وما عبر عنه
باختصار والملعب الان هو اما الاستبداد
واما الحريه اما الكرامه واما الاهانه
فالسيسي سيراوس علب لانه رجل مخابرات لا
يعرف في السياسه ولا يفهم ولا يقدر ان
هناك شيء اسمه حريه حقوق انسان هذه
المفردات مش عنده حين سئل اجتمع بالاحزاب
وسالوه عن الانتخابات كما يقول ابو الغار
دكتور محمد ابو الغار وهو رئيس حزب سالوه
عن الديمقراطيه وحقوق الانسان والانتخابات
والبرلمان اجابهم عن الصرف الصحي قال لهم
احنا عندنا مشكلات في الصرف الصحي وفي قرى
ما عندهاش صرف صحي وبالتالي انت امام
شخصيه لا تؤمن اصلا لا بالعمل المدني ولا
بالعمل السياسي ولا بالعمل الاجتماعي
الجماعي ولا بالديمقراطيه ولا بالحريات
اسمعني هنا يجب ان تتوقف لماذا يراوغ لانه
عيشته حياته مستقبله كله مره في انه يظل
قائدا لهذه المركبه العسكريه اللي ما
فيهاش فرامل هو جاي لهذا والذين جاؤوا به
حينما يشعروا انه اصبح خطرا عليهم ماذا
يعني هذا بالنسبه لحكم على
الرئيس معزول محمد مرسي يعني كل ما شرحته
كل ما شرحته ما الذي او كيف يمكن ان يؤثر
على طبيعه الحكم الذي يمكن ان يصدر
باختصار سيد
حمزه مره اخرى الرئيس نفسه قال حياه ثمن
للشرعيه لا يهمني في المقام الاول ويعرف
السيسي انه الرئيس اشجع واكبر واعظم من
انه يخيفه حكم الاعدام القضيه عند السيسي
مش دي القضيه عند السيسي انه لو كان جريئا
واصدر حكم الاعدام فان هناك ضريبه كلفه
سيدفعها هو والانقلابيين شاء من شاء وابى
من ابى هذه معروفه ليست على المستوى
الخارجي فقط ولكن حتى على المستوى الداخلي
لان ذلك سيشعل الثوره من جديد سيد حتم
عزام هل برايك ان الرئيس السيسي قادر على
اقناع المانيا ومن ورائها الدول الاوروبيه
بسياساته تحت عنوان محاربه الارهاب وبان
يقول انظروا الى ما يجري من حولنا في
الدول العربيه وبالتالي هذه السياسه
الوحيده في هذا الجو القادره على ابقاء
الوضع مستتب في
مصر يعني قد ينجح في بعض الوقت وهنا لازم
نتاكد انه ونكون متصورين انه اوروبا
بتتكلم عن يعني
مؤسسات مختلفه مؤسسات تنفيذيه زي انجلا
ميركل والرؤساء ودول بالضروره بينظروا الى
المصالح ولا يعني يقفون عند المبادئ التي
يدعون لها من الديمقراطيه وحقوق الانسان
بل انه ممثله الاتحاد الاوروبي كاترين
اشتون كان ليها دور يعني اسود في هذا
الانقلاب العسكري انما الشعوب وممثلينها
ومنتخبين زي ما حضرتك تفضلت بالنواب ورئيس
المجلس النواب في المانيا في البوندستاج
مواقفهم منحازه الى خيارات الشعوب الحر
انما دعني اجاوب على السؤال اللي حضرتك
طرحته على مالات هذا الصراع انا بقول
لحضرتك انه في 3/7 الجاي يكون السيسي امضى
عامين على الانقلاب العسكري والحكم وعام
على اغتصاب كرسي السلطه
ا ما حدث في في السنتين الماضيتين يؤكد ان
سيسي لم يدع شيئا او ما يدعى جريمه ضد
الانسانيه الا وقام بها سواء من قتل خارج
نطاق القانون او اعتقال تعسفي او حرق في
عربات الترحيلات او قتل الشباب في الشوارع
او اعتقال المعارضين السياسيين ولم يترك
شيء الا وفعله في هذا الاطار ونجد انه مع
هذا بيستمر الحراك الثوري
وايضا الشعبيه او حجم التاييد الذي كان
حول السيسي من دوائر صنعها هو بنفس نفسي
في 306 تاكلت فلم يبقى له سوى الفنانين
والاعلاميين اللي بيصحب معاه في كل مكان
وبالتالي انا متخيل انه اصدار حكم مثل هذا
هو اصدار حكم على الديمقراطيه في مصر وليس
على شخص الرئيس محمد مرسي الرئيس محمد
مرسي نال شرفا بهذا الحكم ان ان يكون
زعيما للديمقراطيه والحريه ولكن انا لا
اعتقد ان مثل هذه الاحكام
تعالج ما ما يخشاه السيسي هل ستزيد على
السيسي تعقيداته واعتقد انه ستشعل وهج
الثوره المصريه من جديد وانه عبد الفتاح
السيسي يقفز الى الامام ولكنه سيقفز حتما
الى هاويه وسياتي يوم والتاريخ علمنا يا
استاذ حسن ان هناك قاد عسكريين يقودون
الانقلابات ضد المدنيين ثم يفعلوا ما
يفعله السيسي الان ثم يحاكمون وتعود
بلادهم حره بعد بعد ذلك سيد نبيل ميخائيل
هل تعتقد بان السيسي قادر على مواجهه
الضغوط الدوليه وبالتالي يذهب حتى النهايه
في احكام الاعدام يعني هل هل يعطي للمواقف
الدوليه اهميه كبرى رغم ان هذه المواقف
تنتقد سياساته تنتقد القبضه الحديديه وا
يعني كم الافواه في مصر ورغم ذلك هو ماض
في هذه السياسه الان هل تعتقد هو قادر على
مواجهه كل هذا
الضغط طبعا هناك ض احنا في عصر العولمه
الدوله بتتعامل مع كميه معلومات من مختلف
المصادر لكن السيسي نفسه قال ان
الاوروبيين اكثر تفهم لمواقفها عن
الامريكيين يعني البرنامج بيناقش ان
اوروبا تعارض حكومه عبد الفتاح السيسي مع
ان مواقف الاوروبيين بما فيها ميركل اللي
هلتقي بها السيسي النهارده تؤيد الحكومه
في مصر مع اعطاء النصيحه لمصر بضروره
تنفيذ عده امور اهمها عدم اعدام الرئيس
مرسي وعدد من قيادات الاخوان المسلمين
يعني انا بتخيل مثلا ان جناب القاضي هيعلن
نعلن با اعدام المتهمين مع وقف تنفيذ
الحكم مع اي حجه قانونيه قد تستخدم
لوقف تنفيذ هذا الحكم يعني بقى نوع من
المنطق الجمله وما يعارضها ف ما اعتقدش ان
هيكون هناك ازمه خطيره في العلاقات ما بين
مصر وعواصم العالم لان اولا عندهم كميه
مشاكل خطيره انتم عمالين تتكلموا على الم
المانيا طب يا رجد النهارده شوف النيويورك
تايمز عملين يتكلموا المانيا واليونان
خلافات عميقه حول احتمال خروج اليونان من
منطقه اليورو ماحدش بيقول اي حاجه عن
خلافات المانيه مصريه فما فيش حد هيصعد
الخلافات مع مصر هيوب اخوا مصر ينتقدوا
مصر هيوافقوا مع مصر لكن يعني انا نحن لا
نناقش نعم نحن نحن عندما نتحدث عن المواقف
الالمانيه بناء على تصريحات وبناء على
مواقف يعني اخر موقف كان انه رئيس
البرلمان الالماني رفض مقابله السيسي وهذا
له ابعاد كثيره فضلا عن الكثير من النواب
الذين رفضوا لقاءه اضافه الى انهم رفضوا
لقاه الا في اطار اي يعني لقاءات عمل داخل
البرلمان على كل فقد باختصار ل السيد حمزه
زوبع من اسطنبول ما رايك بان المصالح في
نهايه المطاف هي التي
سوف تؤدي الى الغلبه وليذهب مرسي بحكم
اعدام اذا كانت العلاقات المصريه
الالمانيه
مهدده لا اولا الاخ نبيل ميخائيل بيقول لك
انه المانيا عندها مشاكل ده ناقص بكره
يقول لك ان المانيا ميركل ممكن تسقط في
الانتخابات احنا في ايه ولا في ايه
المانيا اقوى دوله في اقتصاد في اوروبا
واقوى دوله اوروبيه لكن ما علينا شوف هناك
الشيزوفرينيا الاوروبيه ما زالت يعني
موجوده الكيل بمكين مازال موجود لكن يحمد
للاوروبيين حتى هذه اللحظه ان رئيس برلمان
اقوى دوله اوروبيه اقتصاديا وسياسيا الان
يقول لا رئيس حزب الخضر يقول لا الالمان
يقولون لا العرب والجاليات والسين في
الخارج يقولوا لا من الذي يقول نعم السيسي
انظر الى طائرته ولتعرف من معه الهام
شاهين ويسرى ومحمد صبحي وبقيه فرقه ح
اشكرك جزيلا
سيد حمزه زوبع من اسطنبول القيادي في حزب
الحريه والعداله ومن فريبور في سويسرا
اشكر حاتم عزام نائب رئيس حزب الوسط
المصري ومن واشنطن نبيل ميخائيل اشكرك
جزيلا استاذ العلوم السياسيه في جامعه
جورج واشنطن شكرا للمتابعه مشاهدينا والى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء
ه